it was a particularly rowdy prime
minister's questions last week keir
starman was accused of being lackluster
heavy on the detail lacking in punch
this week he focused on the economy with
some colorful metaphors
the force just isn't with him anymore
[Applause]
he thinks he's obi-wan kenobi
the truth is he's jabber the heart
he thinks he's on love island
trouble is
prime minister i'm reliably informed
that contestants that give the public
the ick get booted out
when did screwing business turn from a
flippant comment into economic policy
and his questions were much shorter and
snappier than last week britain is set
for lower growth
than every major economy
except russia
why
the labour leader decided to push on the
economy our analysis of his language
shows he focused on words like inflation
growth business the prime minister
wanted to talk about jobs using words
like investment and employment one thing
boris johnson definitely wanted to talk
about was labour's position on rail
strikes what would be useful in
supporting the uk economy right now
would be if the leader of the labour
party ended his sphinx-like silence
about the rmt's strikes coming up in the
course of the next couple of weeks
will he will he now uh will he now break
with his shadow transport secretary and
denounce labour's rail strikes
the pm even prompting a telling off from
the speaker by turning the questions on
to the labour leader just to remind the
prime minister he seems to have gone his
prime minister's question opposition
[Applause]
i don't want the strikes to go ahead but
he does elsewhere the lib dem leader ed
davey was keen to talk about fuel prices
in places like devon a week before a bar
election in devon
the rural fuel duty relief scheme is
supposed to help
by taking money off the price of petrol
but some rural counties aren't eligible
like cumbria
like shropshire
and like devon
a coincidence not lost on the tory
benches
but pmq's was just as interesting for
what kierstarma didn't ask the prime
minister there were no questions on the
big divisive issues of the day by the
northern ireland protocol and the
government's rwanda plan thorny issues
around brexit and immigration labor
wanted to avoid